was ist peter madsen für ein mensch
selbst verliebt und er hat man auch die
psychologen und bestickten
pathologischer lügner
das hat man auch beim prozess gemerkt
dass er wenn er mit den linken
doch kommt sofort der nächste
präsentieren kann oder mit der wimper zu
zucken ist auch die träume davon
geträumt rakete ins all schießen zu
können als alleiniger instrument mit dem
u-boot das war eine ziemliche leistung
also hat er ist fantast und träumen
haben bastler aber eben auch in der
offenbar auch eine sehr dunkle seite hat
und von ganz abgrundtief schlechten
dingen fantasiert und träumt und die
einmal in seinem leben und wirklichen
wollte er war ja vor dem mord 2017 schon
eine bekanntheit im land wofür war er
bekannt er gilt als erfinder als tüftler
was hat er alles gemacht
ja wir wollten eine rakete in die luft
jagen also irgend eine rakete wollte
also wollte eigentlich zum mond fliegen
kann und er war nicht so wahnsinnig
bekannter selten unterbrochen der presse
gewesen der wahrheit nicht besuchen
komische figur in gruppen haben der dann
hafen
das schließt mitte werkstatt hat dann
sieht man was noch alles einfallen lässt
und ja auch leute dazu gebracht hat
gerade flüssig zu arbeiten also konnte
das futter zum beispiel alleine bauen da
waren jede menge leute daran beteiligt
sich mit ihrer arbeitskraft ein also
eine geld das projekt unterstützt haben
er war halt ja sowieso ein liebenswerter
spinner von dem man nicht geahnt hat
dass dann auch ganz andere seiten von
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren